oh
can i meet russell brand
no uh i understand can you meet us
around and persuade him to vote yes
exactly yeah no i'm just here to listen
really and um
yeah i'd like to i'd like to ask
ed miliband
because i'd like to to be uh engaged by
the labour party but i don't feel like
there's a huge difference between them
and the conservative party i'd like him
to
really convince me that uh labor is a
good alternative and a good left
left partly not a center you know what i
mean yeah yeah cool interesting jamal
what about you have you got one question
one burning question um transparency and
allowing me to follow them for sb tv i
think a lot of young people it would be
interesting to see what a politician
does day-to-day and
a lot of people think politicians sit
back with their feet are playing angry
birds or something but i want to show
you do you think they've got time for
that i don't know i read the article
about that someone was on candy crush in
the in the house of parliament
so i'd love
um so yeah i'd love to
get into the house of parliament and
what from when they wake up to when they
go to sleep what do you do because then
if they are actually doing something and
young people will see and if they're not
then questions need to be answered but
isn't it isn't the fact is that probably
a lot of what they're doing is pretty
boring a lot of what they're doing is
probably sitting at a desk reading
papers i'll try and make it fun and i'll
ask them questions to try and get get
stuff out of them